pouvait avec un savoir technique qui est
incomparable aux nôtres en la matière
nous faire un exposé pendant 10 minutes
de virologie pour nous expliquer que le
virus semble muté mais un autre
virologue et milan le professeur lina
nous a expliqué et nous a dit plusieurs
fois que non le virus n'avait pas muté
et ça ça ne fait pas beaucoup avancer
notre compréhension nous nous nous avons
besoin nous ne sommes pas dans des
conflits
ce n'est pas notre méthode ici de mettre
en scène des matchs de catch et de
générer du conflit c'est notre méthode
de faire ressortir les points qui font
clivages et si pour vous ça peut être
pénible parce que vous avez des conflits
avec d'autres collègues d'autres
confrères qui sont parfois effectivement
virulent nous ce n'est pas ce que nous
ce n'est pas notre jaillir ce n'est pas
notre problème j'en suis tout à fait
désolé pour les uns et les autres mais
nous nous devons rendre compte aux
français aux personnes qui résident sur
notre territoire de ce qui s'est passé
et sur ces sujets fondamentaux qui sont
les vôtres la recherche les tests le
dépistage
vous faites partie des personnes qui
avaient une expertise et qui ont été en
désaccord avec d'autres et pouvoir vous
entendre vous répondre entre vous et
pour nous essentiel dans la construction
de notre représentation de notre
compréhension de ce qui se passe ce qui
s'est passé de ce qui se passe voilà
donc je vais pas poursuivre là dessus
mais comprenez juste que nous ne
souhaitions pas vous faire vivre un
moment pénible pour vous à titre
personnel je comprends que ce n'est pas
agréable d'être poursuivi devant des
instances disciplinaires d'avoir des
procédures en justice mais nous nous
avons la nécessité de mener notre
travail dans les meilleures conditions
et très tranquillement professeurs avec
le respect que je vous dois vous ne nous
aidez pas là dans notre tâche votre
exposé est certes très intéressant mais
il ne nous ils ne mettent pas à
progresser de façon suffisante alors je
veux en venir à quelques à quelques
quelques questions non vous allez
répondre à faire il embête pas et vous
allez région venir à quelques
questionnements parce que vous
avait eu là la tension je dirais de nous
envoyer en préliminaire à cette audition
un document extrêmement complet de
réponse à notre question ce matin nous
débattions et nous l'avions fait au
rapporteur rapporteur mais vous ne vous
inquiétez pas je circulais vous avez
tout comprendre
ce matin nous avons eu une discussion et
les jours lors d'auditions présente sur
la question des tests et de la lenteur
je ne refait pas l'histoire du
déploiement des thèses dans notre pays
et au printemps quand nous étions en
pleine vague épidémique
nous voyons tous devant votre institut
des fils de personnes qui venaient pour
faire des têtes et vous pratiquez
beaucoup de tests et dont le document
vous nous avez envoyé vous dites j'ai
fait deux cent mille nous avons faits
liés à je suis deux cent mille tests sur
cent mille personnes alors est ce que
vous pourriez nous préciser ce
calendrier est comme manifestement vous
avez commencé à faire des tests en
nombre très rapidement comment avez vous
fait comment vous êtes vous procurer le
matériel nécessaire les réactifs et
c'est alors que ailleurs en france
bah on n'arrivait pas à faire de tel
donc manifestement vous avez réussi là
où là où on échoué plus tôt donc
j'aimerais que vous me préciser comment
vous avez procédé
la deuxième question c'est nous avait
dit quelque chose de très fort mais nous
vous nous avez dit il ya une destruction
physique de l'organisation des maladies
infectieuses
si j'ai bien compris à paris enfin en
ile-de-france mais j'aimerais que vous
précisiez qu'est ce que c'est que cette
destruction parce que il me semble mais
peut-être le démon tirez-vous alors j'ai
vu aussi qu'il ya des polémiques là
dessus mais il me semble que globalement
les patients qui ont été hospitalisés en
maladies infectieuses en ile de france
n'ont pas eu de perte de chance par
rapport à ceux qui ont été hospitalisés
en maladies infectieuses dans d'autres
régions donc qu'est-ce que cette
destruction physique dont vous avez
parlé j'ai compris que le fait d'avoir
scindé géographiquement mais j'imagine
des services des capacités mais
j'imagine que ça allait au delà puisque
la critique est très dur et puis enfin
dernier point que je ne souhaitais pas
soulevé parce que c'est pas l'obliger
exactement ici mais vous êtes vous êtes
revenu sur diderot xi chloroquine et
l'azithromycine et vous avez dans votre
exposé préliminaire expliqué un principe
qui me paraît très très sens celui du
benchmark vous vous regardez ce qu'il
fallait et rangez vous avez cité la
chine et l'important savoir qu'elle a
qui là qu'elle a accumulées aujourd'hui
il semblerait que la plupart des pays de
des états unis au japon la corée du sud
à l'allemagne en passant par la chine ne
recommande pas ce traitement là donc il
semblerait que la science a parlé et
c'est la liste des pays qui ont qu'ils
ne recommandent pas ou qui même
déconseillent l'utilisation l'hydroxyde
chloroquine est extrêmement longue j'en
ai j'ai cité juste quelques pays et ça
ce n'est pas un jugement sur eure c'est
tout à fait sain de d'entrée quand
nouveaux problèmes arrivent dans la
recherche de médicaments de traitement
possible et deham tenter de trouver que
ça pourrait être efficace mais
aujourd'hui comprenez que nous qui
sommes on va dire des spectateurs
engagés de cette question et la prise en
charge
on constate que dans le monde entier ce
traitement n'est plus utilisé donc est
ce que ça signifie que le monde entier
est aujourd'hui dans l'erreur ah oui
merci vous inquiétez pas vous allez
pouvoir répondre merci bernard ces
questions donc je voulais la parole
professeurs pour la réponse très donc je
pense je ne suis pas d'accord du tout
avec vous et bien sûr sur aucun des
points le premier point le premier point
c'est que la question épaisseur ce n'est
pas un débat entre non non non non mais
si vous avez des affirmations auxquelles
je suis en total désaccord il ya 4,6
milliards de gens qui vivent dans
d'autres pays dans lequel on vit de la
dore livre xi chloroquine donc vous
pouvez pas liquidé ça comme ça je passe
mon temps à faire des méta-analyses rien
que cette semaine il est sorti ce qui
est de sortie en arabie saoudite et en
iran
il en sort à peu près dans tous les pays
du monde donc
on ne peut pas dire ça vous pouvez pas
me dire à moi vous savez mieux que moi
ce que c'est que méta analyse sur
l'hydroxyde vous avez une opinion et
vous voyez bien qu'il n'est pas possible
de sur les pions c'est le temps qu'il
fait les opinions vous savez encore une
fois si vous aviez demandé au départ à
quoi sert la 14ème mois je disais à
partir de février à 14h c'est un
fantasme analogique avec la quarantaine
ça n'a pas de sens sur le plan clinique
c'est pas vrai d'accord la donne il ya
d'ailleurs une une étude de méta analyse
qui fait partie du rapport que je vous
ai envoyés et que bien entendu il peut
être distribué à tout le monde
la deuxième chose c'est que le temps
encore une fois fait le tri au début les
gens disaient ça ne sert à rien de faire
des tests pourquoi ils n'ont pas fait
des tests par cette parce que les
centres nationaux de référence lors on
dit écoutez c'est compliqué difficile de
faire des tests et une fois que cet
embranchement était parti il est
extrêmement difficile de revenir sur cet
embranchement extrêmement difficile et
donc c'est pas vrai qu'il n'est pas les
réactifs je les dis je le redis puis je
vous le redis encore une fois si vous
voulez les laboratoires vétérinaires ont
écrit à peu près à tout le monde y
compris au conseil scientifique pour
leur dire qu'ils avaient de faire quoi
300 mille tests et les autres n'auront
pas répondu et nous on a répondu et on
s'en est servi
d'accord donc vous ne pouvez pas penser
que dans une crise comme ça où il ya des
opinions différentes
vous avez les par la magie du sénat
faire que les gens votent d'accord la
fin c'est le temps qui trient le temps
tri et la la fin on voit ce qui s'est
passé d'accord c'est à la fin qu'on voit
ce qui s'est passé quand encore une fois
à la ligue roc cyclo pin et donc pour
les tests on a fait ce qu'on fait quand
on est en situation de crise c'est à
dire tous les jours on s'est débrouillé
nous mêmes on a fabriqué de quoi faire
430 mille tests nous même chez nous
l'eau phillies est d'accord on s'est
organisé pour faire face ces
l'intendance qui a suivi la décision
c'est pas la tendance qui a commandé la
décision c'est comme ça qu'on a vu les
choses et c'est comme ça que je
continuerai à les voir quant à votre
opinion sur qui et kind en taille rossi
chloroquine je vous assure je viens
d'avoir un papier accepté sur lequel on
a mis l'ensemble des pays qui
recommandait reed roxy chloroquine la
mortalité dans l'ensemble des pays qui
regardait avec lockheed et ça n'est pas
ce que vous dites donc je ne suis pas le
porte donc vous évitez vous émettez une
opinion
scientifique et donc vous voyez je ne
suis pas de corps et donc que chacun
fasse son métier et les vaches seront
bien gardées vous entendrez deux éco et
le tente rire à la fin on verra bien si
vous nous bien sûr tu sais danser je
sais pas encore dans le document je
crois c'est dans l'autre c'est dans le
jeu qui manque c'est dans le document
que nous communiquons bien sûr
l'ensemble de nos conseillers parce que
la lecture et il est intéressant de nos
conduits serpent monsieur le président
je ne suis pas dans un débat d'opinion
je suis rapporteur d'une co je suis
rapporteur d'une commission denquête les
professeurs je vais vous citer une liste
incomplète d'ailleurs des pays qui
actuellement dans les autorités de santé
des conseils d' usage de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine si ce que disent ces
autorités et inexact je veux bien
l'entendre je veux bien entendre votre
opinion qui ne la partage pas et vous ne
pouvez pas dire que c'est une opinion de
ma part aux usa là ni h et lignes fixes
diseases society of america
déconseillent l'utilisation l'aude roxy
chloroquine en grande bretagne c'est
déconseillé dans le monde l'organisation
mondiale de la santé de demande de ne
pas l'utiliser quelle que soit la
gravité l'italie des conseils la
belgique déconseille l'allemagne
déconseille le brésil le portugal la
chine le chinese center for disease
control and prevention estime que
l'utilisation doit être déconseillé
quelle que soit la gravité le japon
l'australie l'espagne le canada
l'european medicines agency pour
l'europe la suisse et la corée du sud
je n'aimais pas une opinion si ces
recommandations sont erronées je peux
l'entendre et jeu j'attends qu'on nous
l'expliquent mais je ne vais pas mené de
débats scientifiques avec vous ce n'est
pas le sujet je réfute simplement
professeur le fait que vous transformiez
ma question en un débat d'opinion entre
vous et moi je respecte votre opinion et
je vous aimez les recommandations des
pays concernés encore une fois je vous
recommande de vous verrez encore
on a un papier dans lequel on explique
ça extrêmement précisément sondés
général vous savez pour faire des
généralités trouvé qu'on est d'accord
c'est extrêmement simple moi je peux
vous dire aux états unis et ajuste un
pays fédéral il ya un tiers des états
dans lequel hydroxy feront il est
recommandé il ya un tiers des états dans
lequel ils savent pas trop ce qu'il faut
faire et un tiers des états qui suivent
les recommandations de fossiles
c'est un pays fédéral donc il n'ya pas
d'homogénéité aux états unis et compare
même aux états unis à des conflits les
conflits autour de l'hydroxyde de
routine sont mondiaux qui compare même
aux états unis état par état
quelle est la mortalité liée aux
qu'ovide par rapport à la prescription
ou non d'une russie turquie pardon la
liste oui oui vous la regarderai la
liste nous on a fait une liste on a
marqué chaque source
à chaque de chaque source d'où elle
vient comment est fait comme on fait de
la séance donc vous vous le lirez vous
avez si vous souhaitez que je vous
enlevez le vol près print je vous
enverrai n'y a pas de problème mais moi
je le fais il se trouve que c'est un
sujet sur lequel vous imaginez bien
qu'on travaille
nous on a estimé qu'il ya 4,4 à 10,6
milliards de gens qui vivaient dans les
pays dans lequel ont recommandé ou en
tout ont dit vous pouvez dire l'année
d'auxi chloroquine se voulait donc il
encore une fois donc ça veut dire que
ces débats qui sont des débats
scientifiques très bien nous on l'a
écrit il ya une liste une liste des
sources comme on a l'habitude de faire
et puis et puis voilà vous regarderez si
vous arrivez à les analyser
où vous les ferez analysés par quelqu'un
qui vous aidera à les analyser mais on
ne peut pas de manière péremptoire dire
écoutez tous ces pays là ne le font pas
elles ne l'ont pas fait parce que c'est
pas mal